and Jon taffer's here John I saw that
proper proper introduction from bar
rescue
the inventor rescue of the bus funnel I
was talking to somebody about the butt
funnel yesterday and they was a minor
they didn't understand the brilliance of
it and I had to try to explain to them
cuz I've watched who are you talking to
about text I was Jen alright it was like
she said that she gets creeped out when
guys use excuses to try to get social
with her and I go no Jen there's
anything that I know about bars and I
never go to bars but there's anything
that I know about bars it's that the bar
business is what a social social
business that's what I said isn't it now
the buff funnel takes all the excuses
out of it right Roxy do you know about
the bud I'm assuming it's a funnel in
your butt thirty six thirty inch or so
entrance to a dance floor right so let's
say I see you approached the dance floor
I like you
so I tie myself said that the two of us
have to go through the butt funnel at
the same time
so as we approached the butt funnel
there's a big choice right do we go in
face to face or ass ass or asked to face
right Jim you see gasps the face when
you go through the butt photo you're
real excited because she's facing you
Yeah right I did it the last minute she
turns but if she doesn't turn that means
it's meant to be got a chance right now
you I saw you outside speaking to Sharon
taking a photo with her life
are you just a fan oh sure well I've met
her once before I've never taken a
picture with her before sure I am and
it's the same thing last his life you
know I love her unto herself the most
people you meet know who you are cuz
you're pretty famous guy yeah you know
the past year year and a half it's
really taken off Jimmy yeah and last
week I was on TV 41 hours Sunday Mara
this week oh that's right Oh Sunday no
no but it's on now from 8 to noon Monday
through Friday and I'm sitting with your
network and they're telling me how they
try friends
Bar rescue beer this is a ten in the
morning on weekdays
they tried mom they tried cops bar
rescue keeps beating them all I think
this season our numbers are higher than
last season I mean heck it over I think
I've told you this before but I used to
before his doing the morning show is
doing a solo show I was working nights
so IV up late every night because my
show wouldn't come on until 9 o'clock so
I'd be up till 3:00 or 4:00 in the
morning and Sundays
my wife would go to bed nine ten o'clock
whatever it is because she had a regular
schedule and I would sit there on Sunday
nights until two o'clock in the morning
from the time from 10 o'clock until 2:00
three o'clock in the morning yeah watch
another bar rescue
yeah watch another bar rescue and it
became every Sunday it's unbelievable
and if they don't run a new episode that
night the marathon doesn't quite do as
well so is that what starts what kicks
off the marathon is the new episode well
if there isn't a new episode that night
the marathon doesn't do as well it seems
to make a difference so they keep buying
them so how many new ones do you do per
superior well I've been doing 40 a year
yeah this year I was at 2:30 oh it's
almost all year that's really that it's
five days in episode so it's you know
you're talking 200 days in a row you do
you like it though I like he's at least
you're busy and you feel like I'm doing
something I'm not wasting away and my
career is certainly not ending so
changing people's lives yeah you know to
be relevant this long Jim is a pretty
gratifying thing you know I'm a freaking
love it but but it's tough when you're
on the road that long I'll tell you
what's interesting at the end of every
episode and I'm not trying to be a moral
here or Noble at the end of every
episode two things happen I get a check
and I get a hug the hug means more to me
these days in the check yeah yeah take
the check if it wasn't for the way I
feel after each one I'm not sure I would
do it anymore but you actually like when
it works out in somebody's business is
back to where it should be or maybe it's
even more than that I look in their eyes
I can see the difference it's amazing
how they stand different their facial
expressions you can see it on TV
absolutely it's a really powerful thing
to think that you can change somebody's
life that much your
eager to do it again wait and then what
happens is when I beat the hell out of
it oh yeah you do and then I get that
hog at the end yeah what you guys never
hear and I wish you could
Sam is you never hear what said when we
hug because our microphones are on our
chest so when we hug each other you
don't hear it
those moments are the most powerful to
me the things they whisper in my ear at
that moment some believe it's a Bill
Murray and Scarlett Johansson nobody
knows that translation very much like
Stockholm Syndrome in the sense that you
beat them into submission
by the end of it they're just worshiping
you is what you do to people
I've always wondered I feel like I've
got part one of Jon Taffer down meaning
I've gotten quite good at beating people
into submission but the second part
where it feels like you're actually
empowering them and they thank you for
it
I can never get that here's what happens
after they go like that Sam Roberts what
a [ __ ] [ __ ]
every morning some people think that we
amorous calls it to Howard Stern Factor
okay right well you could look at
somebody tell them to go F themselves
challenge him is a man challenge a human
and then a minute later they hug you
right and it's I don't know how to do it
but you do it but I don't know how it
just happens this is not a conscious
thing we don't think likes us when all
of a sudden that person is nice to us
like oh god that guy doesn't like me but
then you know he does like me it's a
great feeling and you want to hug
someone so if someone is not great to
you or you feel they're harsh with you
and also they're nice to you that goes a
long way I think that's true I'm hoping
that that happens between you and I at
some point I think it can happen you've
never been mean to me always been nice
no I think psychologically I think you
know a lot about human psychology I
think that's what you're using because I
feel like you find these people and you
know when somebody's got a paternal
complex meaning they're looking for a
father figure I do and a lot of times
you can walk come on Sandusky turn our
but I think you know when somebody's
looking for a father figure and you can
tell when they're not looking for Bar
advice from you just bar advice they
need dad's approval out of you I think
that's true especially a second third
fourth fifth year the show that I think
that's becomes more and more true yeah
as they get bigger than life because the
television to them but you know what's
interesting is every failing business is
a failing owner right so you know I
always that's why when I walk in I
always focus on the individual more than
a business
I mean his baby owner breaking he
doesn't notice dirt right his bar is
dirty for another reason right right so
there's always a reason behind the
reason why would the bar be dirty what
did I usually say about a guy of his
bars dirty maybe he gave up on life
maybe his car is just as dirty maybe his
relationship with his wife is just as
dirty you know I mean if his life is
disorganized in that fashion that's deep
you know Jim so how do you change the
attitude that causes that to happen I
can tell him to go clean his bar mm-hmm
but tomorrow it's gonna be the same
thing if I said there's something in his
head that's causing this you need to
change the the way of thinking the
psychology of what he's doing so that he
just looks at things differently so that
you can maintain whatever it is that you
set up for him yes let me say two
different way I don't want to tell you
don't do this don't do that do this do
that I don't want to change what you do
I want to change the way you think right
so it's the ones I could change the way
you think right then I can't help change
what you do but that gets ugly
challenging everything you don't
freaking like it it's hard to get people
like it's easy to say you did something
fix that will you start telling somebody
they're thinking it's [ __ ] up it's
very difficult for people to accept that
that's when it gets personal
yeah how do you but if I don't get them
to accept that mm-hmm nothing changes so
it has to go there that's the most
heated parts of bar rescue is when they
blame it on someone else that's the
competition adds the it's the president
they always have another reason why
they're failing oh yeah so I have to
make them on it right right yes you got
a frickin onus and you got to take the
blame and if I can get you to doubt
yourself just for a minute then I can
walk in
crack and that victim mentality is is is
sort of all-encompassing isn't it come
on get yourself together so sometimes
they need a good ass-kicking how do you
do it in two days though because like
you know we got guys on staff I won't
mention shitloads names all the [ __ ] or
love but he it's just in one ear out the
other every single thing that gets said
mistake same mistakes over and over
again and I'm sitting there and I watch
bar rescue because to me I don't even
drink I don't care about bars to me I
feel like this is just a guy talking
about a business and the way one runs a
business and Zoo battery and humans
really right but how how does one get
across to somebody that works for them
like Italy how do you break that cycle
well there's just three ways that I try
to do it yeah one I'll appeal to their
pride do you like being an idiot to
watch a grown man who works in the bar
industry have to look at Jon Taffer and
go no I actually want to answer that's a
good question no I don't either
yeah so do you understand that everybody
else says you're an idiot
right right right somehow you have to
miss pride is one the other one is fear
so if you keep being an idiot you're
gonna lose your house aren't you
right your wife's gonna leave you two
aren't you you're gonna have no friends
you're not gonna have it done so if you
continue to be an idiot you have nothing
so fear is a really really powerful one
pride and fear the two biggest than I
use then the third one that I use and I
sound like a psychiatrist and I'm not
rest transference I'll say okay so
you're an idiot do you realize how much
you being an idiot hurt your wife
meaning if you're okay being an idiot
that's fine but now you're affecting
other people you're hurting your
right there was one episode where I said
to a guy I want you to look in this
glass and every time you look in this
bottom of this glass I want you to see
your son
oh dude in that glass I want you to see
your frickin son now have a drink
you know it's drunk work yeah it helps
for your big guy though
yeah because those are fighting words
yes Paul William said that it probably
wouldn't have sometimes the biggest ones
are the ones that are the most images
big guys aren't used to being told to go
F themselves right right they're not
used to being challenged that way so
when I come up to them and I get in
their face like whoa they're very
uncomfortable with it it's very
different it's got very uncomfortable so
I think the biggest ones the bigger ones
fall the fast those little guys have
that complex and little guys are very
confrontational with your friends
because Keven Undergaro owner of the
studio afterbuzz I've seen you with him
and at his house before you are very
gentle with your friends I've never seen
you raise your voice to anybody do you
get in your family and friends face like
that if they're doing something wrong
never Oh but-but-but Kevin's not failing
right but I'm sure you have some friends
in the family who was about to leave
Kevin because Kevin was a jerk I would
be screaming at Kevin as loud have you
seen me on television because he would
mean it right and I would be making a
positive difference in his life if
there's no reason if it doesn't move our
lives positive I won't do it
because I'm not about the negativism I'm
about the positive aspect of what it
turns into turning it into something
good turn it around you like the second
part of the show where we end on the
happy note look at what we started with
look at what we've got now yes almost
like you said before Sam you know when
you say you're good at beating them up
the trick is to put them back together
again right it's really hard though when
if somebody you love especially I mean
you're just dealing with people you
don't know it's really hard when you
can't get somebody to change when you're
watching them on the edge of a cliff and
you're like they're gonna jump and I
can't stop it I can't I can only do so
much
I can I can I can give a great soliloquy
I can talk and it doesn't move them it
doesn't fix it you can't save a person
from themselves and there's times where
it just doesn't work
you gotta anger them I find that if I
can anger people it can really be a very
powerful thing sometimes I want you to
be emotional not logical so I'm gonna
keep going at you until you get
emotional and you can't be afraid for
them to not like you in the moment right
here's the thing when you're emotional
you're not reserved right if I can get
you emotional everything's gonna come
out right you're not gonna hold back
when you're emotional you are gonna
freaking cut loose so if I can piss you
off enough and get you to cut loose I'm
gonna learn everything that's going on
angers my friend not my enemy I was
watching an episode and I've seen this
episode of hundred times it's one of my
favorites but it was the one in a bar
you've seen it yes it was the one where
you where you watch the dad come in and
smack the [ __ ] out of this kid I was
having episode and then you go in and it
is heavy and I'm sitting there going
like this guy Jon Taffer signed up to
fix a bar and all of a sudden he's
becoming a family therapist do you get
into situations where you're like the
group of people here need a lot more
than Jon Taffer
like I don't need to take on this
responsibility not really actually
you know I've I'm not a doctor right but
you know I have studied psychology you
have yes and I am just reading and
studying human behavior and such I'm a
study of it and I believe that I can
help that person I do so so what I do is
I expose them to the truth and I let
them sort of help themselves but I I
always feel and let me tell you a great
example there was one of my favorite
episodes is the one with the Dominican
Republic couple from the Dominican
Republic
Edith annd and John John John P I guess
his name was yes but typical Dominican
name when I started the episode you guys
know I don't have any briefing it when I
started the episode the wife got in the
car with me to do recon and she had a
little gift bag with her I know this
episode and I said sure what's in the
bag and she said divorce papers it's my
husband
well I beat the hell out of that husband
unlike any episode ever and I ended the
episode he cried to me thanked me for
being the father he never had they put
the engagement ring back on but what
nobody knows is three months later I got
an email from them they had a baby and
their lives have been turned around and
I get dizzy
all the time so I'm obviously doing
something right so it inspires me to
keep going at what point did you realize
like okay I got helping people down I
got the bar business down now I'm
figuring out how to make good television
decisions on the fly because you did
something this season and it was
actually this I'm watching the episode
and this was the moment where I'm
watching the episode and I texted Roland
and said hey his taffer around can he
come to the show and he's in LA because
I want to ask him this you told one of
the the guy who runs the bar did he had
to fire his girlfriend who was the
bartender and in Taffer walks in he said
you know the bar is a mess the
girlfriend is the bartender and in front
of the girlfriend so the guy the girl
knows that not only is that guy gonna
fire her but he's gonna fire her because
Taffer told him to and he goes if you
don't you fire your girlfriend tonight
and I'll come back tomorrow goodbye and
he leaves and I go I don't know if a
producer whispered it in his ear but in
terms of television I'm sticking around
to see if that guy's gonna fire a single
fire
yep let me tell you something that and I
say this is he did I say this on my
mother's grave yeah no producer ever
whispers anything in my ear ever so
you're this per year I am my story
producer I'm the executive producer of
the show there's no briefing
there's no setups there's no actors
there's no scripts I go in and I follow
the story and I do whatever I want for
four days now do you know this is gonna
be great TV when I do the fire your
girlfriend deal not to say everything is
gonna be great TV okay I just think it's
gonna be a powerful moment for him if I
play the TV I'm gonna fail it becomes
[ __ ] yeah because you're gonna come
you're gonna not be genuine because
you're gonna think it's gonna be too big
or too small and the cast will know it
the employees will know the minute they
think I'm playing to the camera Jim yeah
they don't they laugh at me it's not
real anymore there's no threat No
so the cameras disappeared to me I'm
lucky about that the cameras really
disappeared and it's me and you and
there's nobody else in this room but me
and you right now
right so
right now what do you need to do you
need to step up and be a man right now
you shouldn't have your girlfriend
working in a bar that's completely
illogical I'm only here for three days
I'm dealing with that right now
rats what's going through my head do you
think you've rehired her or no I don't
believe he did actually but there's a
lot of those moments you know there was
an episode that aired a few weeks ago
where I looked at the husband he was
that country guitar player mm-hmm right
and I looked at him as one of the
heaviest lines I ever said and bar
rescue I looked in his eyes and I said
you realize your wife thinks a lot less
of you today than the day she married
you he needed to hear that sure he did
but for a man yeah for another man to
tell you that that's powerful
but it's gonna change your ass isn't it
it's gonna make you think now when your
way that's powerful man but but you know
I'm there for three and a half days
right I have to be powerful I have to be
impactful no never taking a swing at you
no yeah that's why it works for TV not
because I'm playing for TV but because
the time is so condensed that I'm a
maniac right that I have no time to mess
with any of this she's God now I'm not
waiting till tomorrow right you know
you're gonna fix this now there is no
tomorrow so I think it's that time
compression that drives you work well
when you're stressed debt well you're
stressed because you got I got a lot to
do in three days oh yeah I'm great no
sir you don't stand the time ever you
have extended to five days well there
was one episode with a four collapsed
you know so we had a physical one of the
hurricane episodes we pushed a couple of
inches it was a big remodel but no and
the remodels are always less than 36 37
hours we always shoot in four days yeah
you know what happens is we've talked
about this before I do recon right after
recon we turn off the cameras put all
the employees and vans in the parking
lot I design the bar that night people
don't realize that I do design it myself
I sign off on every bar stool every
piece of wallpaper every recipe every
logo that's what makes it real I own it
right so it's got to be good right the
logo matters to me the drinks matter to
me the wallpaper matters is your name is
going on in
what really matters to me is that you're
going in right and you're telling all
these people you suck you're doing it
wrong I do it right so you should do it
how I say I've had that set in my
bedroom but if that doesn't work that's
on you by how many people she's let's
bring it down by race never though when
you look at the stories you win and you
tried so hard and then you read
somewhere you see somewhere that they
just went back to the way they were
doing it yeah you know I in the
beginning I did be used to bother it
doesn't bother me at all now and here's
who fgo is it's about 70% of them are
successful so I have no problem talking
about the other 30% I challenge anyone
else to be thirty seventy percent
successful in this situation where
they're in debt they tell us they're in
debt they're on cont we have to write
checks to keep the lights on sometimes
while we're shooting I'm gonna come to
turn the power off while we're there so
I'm really proud of what happens if they
turn it back I have sort of the attitude
you know the comedian Ron White sure he
says there's no fixing stupid so you
know some people you just can't help
yourself destructive or or whatever
which is unbelievable because it failed
are they ever telling the truth about
the outside circumstances that you're
like oh yeah that is kind of [ __ ]
that's interesting you know it's yes and
no they could have a difficult situation
in the competitive or their location or
no Parker but they're about to be on
national television that show is gonna
air 17 to 18 times this year right if
they sees that people will come from
miles so anybody who's embraced it has
done really really well yeah just you
know what happens to know a little bit
Jim as it takes 8 to 10 weeks by the
time we shoot to show to when it airs so
they have to survive those 10 weeks
right till it hits the air they they
have to market they have to promote
which they're not good at some of them
make it those 10 days some of them don't
how do you feel about because you said
the cameras disappear which means that
you're not sitting there trying to put
on a show yeah yeah and you yourself
like you're not trying to present
yourself as anything but you but there
are plenty of people who watch the show
or say why no why
that show cuz that guy's an [ __ ] I
don't know why that guy's got to go in
and be a [ __ ] [ __ ] all the time I'm
not watching a guy yell at a bunch of
people do you ever feel like I want to
prove those people well I don't want
those people to think that way cuz
that's not true i or do you just not
care can I say the f-word
you can still [ __ ] them million unique
viewers of watch bar rescue
so you say [ __ ] it's not thirty for a
hundred channels and four languages if
somebody wants to call me an [ __ ] let
him call me a name sure I know in my
heart that I'm doing good work and I'm
trying to change people's lives and you
know I'm trying to be inspirational
you like being you don't you it's fun
being you it is you guys know me well
we've been together yeah different than
I am no camera no no I don't find you'd
be different at all you know I've talked
to you a whole bunch and I've watched
your home life it's the reason why you
guys are successful is cuz you're
authentic right you know you are always
Sam and you are always Jim and you never
step out of that box no no I never step
out of that box he never steps out of
that closet
you know authenticity and that's what
people blow it is is they lose that
authentic see through in a minute yeah
you watch people try to play to the
audience that they don't have instead of
just being yourself and embrace the
audience that you have right you know
when I started to show Sam everybody
says you know you gotta do this you
gotta do that you've this this and I
said to myself you know I just don't
want to do any of that I'm gonna be me
and either I'm gonna fail being me or
I'm gonna succeed being me but I'm not
gonna blame this on somebody else when
I'm done right so how does the show
start this do you go to spike at the
time now paramount and say I don't know
if you know me I'm afraid yeah what
happened was it's actually funny story
somebody came up he was giving a speech
at a convention something cousin he said
you should be on TV so I write this
three-page write-up originally called on
two rocks and I bring it to a friend of
mine who run this television for
Paramount and I show it to him I would
say his name and I show it to him and he
looks and he goes John you'll never
[ __ ] be on television you're too old
you're not good-looking enough [ __ ] it
it'll never happen yeah
and I say you know [ __ ] this I'll do it
myself so I shot my own sizzle reel
three minutes long and I brought it to
four production companies I got four
offers in five days
Wow all four called me
what's on the sizzle reel that you just
isn't real was me going to a friend's
bar that was empty screaming and yelling
at his employees he had a big Pittsburgh
Steelers following the next day so I
shot the bar empty on Saturday shot it
full on Sunday oh my god and that was
three minutes long in the empty bar full
bar screaming people that's the only
time you've done a fake show that's the
only thing I've ever done that's right
that's great because it was all faked at
a friend's bar right so I did the sizzle
reel we sent this is a real to the four
companies got four offers it shows three
ball because they had the Biggest Loser
at the time which was a really good show
I thought they were a good production
company signed with three balls spike
picked up the show four days later and
in less than a year from when that
person told me I will never [ __ ] be
on television to show premiered now 189
episodes
eight years later and 3,400 channels I
love calling him and just reminding him
it's a new season it's a news he was
giving me what he thought was honestly
all right just cause you say it doesn't
mean it's just wrong yeah you use the
same mixologist the same chef and a lot
of sure it's not every show but there
are a couple of them that end up on the
majority of the shows do you how do you
feel about the fact that you've turned
them into celebrities as well it's great
yeah I think it's great there's
interesting thing about bar rescue those
you know we always look at the experts
and of course we look at ratings and
those things there is no correlation
between any expert on bar rescue and
ratings hmm it's fascinating it's the
show itself it's the show itself right
so you know so what know if they
replaced the host I'll bet there would
be a difference in that so we we you
know bring mixologist and based on
personality there's no ratings to drive
those decisions right so this season we
start in February bringing in a whole
bunch of new ones just for fun just to
see yeah just have some fun Wow today
ever yell at the people to or know that
all your job they yell to people
sometimes the kitchen guys do I noticed
i certainly want them to how you doing
yeah I want them to be honest you know
if they come on just yell at people and
you guys do recon we've talked about it
let's do it should make it happen two
seasons we were just going see going to
one of the
Barr's we order a whole bunch of food I
like the episodes we're like what Taffer
does right he'll figure out that the
kitchen is like really lazily raw and
they they go super slow so he sends the
Recon people in and they order like 15
items I'm gonna try the nachos I'm gonna
get a pizza let me get the chicken wings
let me get these and like then you just
get to see the hidden camera in the
kitchen and the the cooks are going like
Oh what the [ __ ] I don't know I'm not
gonna and everything is screwed they
don't know that there's a camera in the
kitchen er they forget they forget the
cameras going about two days earlier and
it's amazing Jim they forget you know
you also say we might not do the show
we're just putting the stars in we do a
lot of stuff right I don't want to
reveal my secrets but sometimes we'll
hang extra lighting in the bar extra
sound and lighting equipment and then a
few minutes before we start shooting
I'll send my crew in to remove some
lights and they'll say sorry guys he
went to another bar decided down the
minute we start pulling the lights down
the bottles and the shots contracts
already like I I have to fake them out
to make it real tomorrow so we're
constantly screwing with them to try to
make with their pants down oh yeah I
would love to see when I walk in and
they say aw [ __ ] here he is you know you
can't fake that stuff yeah yeah I don't
know let's go y'all people on the other
side I definitely you have to eat really
bad food though I would just overact Oh
these nachos are from Harry I'm a snob
but I really am I oh my god I've eaten
with I'm a very particular man doing a
gentleman service and he's very you
suffer five Jim is very babies so Jim
used to live in an apartment full of
black mold yeah with his other comedy
buddy Florentine and just was a
and he got successful and you talk about
your sellouts of all selves
he has a guy that calls hotels ahead to
make sure that it's feather pillows not
other pillows when he goes to like
Montreal to the comedy festival he won't
stay in the hotel with the other
comedians cuz the sheets are too itchy
that's right so he stays at a fancier
hotel no not always fancier though not
always fancier I've actually left I'll
leave a Westin to stay in a courtyard
marriott because i can sleep there he
means he's particularly right the sheet
yes i do the hotel with comedians i mean
i could no i don't want to i just i like
certain things and the feather pillows i
can't sleep on the other words I'm an
insomniac so I have to eat and this is
why it'd be valuable to you and well
we'd be value yeah sure is that he'll
his facial expressions I don't even know
if he's doing him half the time but like
you're looking at him and you're going
like well what's he upset about now like
he K doesn't he never hides up like you
look at food and yeah oh man with the
food you get on bar rescue made some
serious facial expressions I'll try to
come up with a catchphrase like what
would you say I wouldn't feed this to
bees yeah food is so bad I wouldn't [ __ ]
it right this food is so bad I wouldn't
yeah yeah and then you could have
t-shirts and say I wouldn't [ __ ] it I
wouldn't I like when the because when
Taffer walks into the bars
everybody knows who it is because he's
become a celebrity yeah but a lot of
times the chefs when especially when
it's not one that's been on a whole
bunch of episodes nobody knows who he is
and there have been episodes were Taffer
since the chef in first so all of a
sudden these guys are just in the
kitchen you know jerking off ur or
cursing about something or being upset
and they that chef that Tavor is hard
will walk in and you'll start yelling at
them and they'll be in this like state
of confusion like who are you my
favorite one tampers in the car and he's
looking at the most disorganized bar
he's ever seen in his life it's
ridiculous he goes what I want you to do
I want you to go in there make yourself
a pizza and walk out with it and the guy
goes okay and you just see this guy just
a guy who eat mean he's a chef but he's
doesn't know correlation with the bar he
walks in he takes the pizza out of the
oven he puts it in a box he walks right
out the bar not one person even bats an
eye and so what's 1/2 or walks in he
goes this guy just walked out with those
are great moments yeah faked that stuff
now so what has to happen is that has to
happen in real time yeah that's why bar
rescue can't be planned right so at that
moment that's just an idea that pops
into your head no different than the
stuff we're doing now I mean you can't
plan a radio show like yours right you
know it's got to be real so you know
those are moments that we at that moment
that seemed right so you did it see yeah
when you plan it when you script it it
just doesn't feel as comfortable or is
that but there's also room for
sloppiness or clumsiness I mean like we
[ __ ] up I ask dumb questions we trip on
it means that's all a part of it but
that happens in bar rescue you know we
have we sometimes have to caption it
because we didn't get the audio right
you know sometimes you can't see the
scene so I have to do a little interview
to explain what just happen
it's real so the cameramen do miss
things and let's be honest if they took
our 3-hour radio show that we just do
every day and we got some professional
editors to cut it into a nice solid like
hour in 50 minutes okay I was gonna say
60 minutes show I would think you
probably get a good three to four
minutes at the cameraman when they miss
something sometimes when we really blow
something because we can't do it again
there's no second chance at it and then
we need to know better we need to be on
those moments and really work that stuff
so sure there's a lot of pressure on a
crew but after 180 nine episodes we're
really good at this now so we have a
great anticipation together the greatest
moments is when the guys with the big
show the cameras are running backwards
but that the most challenging moments
you'll get a kick out of this gym is
when somebody quits because when
somebody who it's oh yeah I'll cast
myself cashman been a boy so when
somebody quits they like ripped their
micro
Radio enemy's radio enemy's on-air
rescuing me you know I was a producer
before I was a host and there is
apartment I watched your show I wish
more people were actually interested in
like you market to market to rest Real
Radio sure cuz I would love to go into
some of these dopey shows that are just
awful and just break down everything
they're doing wrong yeah I think it'd be
great I think so I like it radio Trey do
chums we rescue shows that's right
that's right now John III should ask you
we were talking to Roxy earlier she is
27 newly single oh yeah beautiful that's
right however she's having a tough time
she doesn't she was told earlier this is
the salad portion of her life meaning
this is the beginning the appetizer
right this is the good part
he changed it to breadbasket eventually
let me tell you this whatever you're
doing two years from now is gonna be a
lot cooler than what you're doing now
right why do you say that because it's
just a I've watched you for a year or so
I've watched you on the after shows that
you do I'm feeling your presence now I'm
looking at your appearance your persona
you're sitting here doing this because
you have a passion a spirit for
something you're good at it when you
talk about keys
so you know I think that at some point
these guys gonna be working for you on
your life trust me hang in there this is
gonna get better
thank you John I told her that a year
ago she don't listen to me unless you
know what if salads sucks and she's
better off without some [ __ ] ankle
weight on her
oh yeah if some guys said no to you yeah
welcome he's just like hard Wow Gibby
why well he was not currently hard
there's other pressures just couldn't
deal with the pressure of your beauty
thank you that's what it was Revere
confidence did or did he say it was
something else
yeah what do you say I think he wanted
to be with other women a young guy go
for it but so you'll find the girl but
here's where Taffer is right a couple of
years from now now that you're
independent right you're not in the
you're not in them in the mode of
impressing him all the time you're just
out for Roxy again just out for yourself
a couple years from now he'll trust me
when I tell you and I told you this
before he'll be on the decline
you're still going up that's when he's
gonna hit you up again and by then he'll
be so yesterday's news
yesterday's tomatoes yes I'm sorry he'll
be so yesterday's tomatoes which is
actually a phrase yeah popular phrase
but you'll find it laughable don't you
think that's true John I do think it's
true Nick I think couple years from
Megan to see him with some girlfriend
sure I didn't say oh my god he got what
he deserves
absolutely as you're walking down the
street arm in arm with Jim Norton the
fresh smell of your urine walking around
smell like a [ __ ] urinal mentioned
the tool appreciate what he had right
he's an idiot
you'll find someone who does yeah in
this city no what do you think Jim yeah
I'm just hoping he means me too
[Laughter]
yes absolutely it's like I always say
Jim the belt is not the answer
you know Jim was with two women just
last night to really do that
simultaneously but I think that's even
more offensive one after the other very
impressed I couldn't do that yeah I
couldn't handle ya see that at least you
can still do that like oh god I'm not
gonna have sex with somebody for so many
years I think you should help her with
this I would do whatever she needed if
you help her break the ice I think it
would be a very very charitable act we'd
have to sleep together we just go out
for a dinner date I'm a really fun
dinner date what kind of food do you
like yeah I'm a good conversationalist
Italian um okay he doesn't need pasta oh
yeah I do he's a Japanese what about a
good pastrami sandwich yeah he so you
know right because of your heritage a
Gentile girl and she's gonna pay retail
for everything I'm gonna send this to
him to blow them with her friends time I
tuned in I'm like so far gone good fun
dinner date okay oh yeah yeah I don't
think my videos I mean I've got a dinner
with him it's well it's not a date
either a friends remarkably uneventful
lunch together
oh yeah it's nice Raso is brief I eat
poorly I think you should go out with
five different guys five different
nights in a row post all the pictures
that's a good move that's right
we're your sexiest clothes make it look
like these guys are having a night of
their life yes yes while you are but
funnily
I've learned from Maria Menounos instead
of posting sexy pics you productive ones
so I interviewed Ron Perlman this
morning we talked to Sharon Stone we
talked to Jon Taffer those are the posts
I picked well you know what I mean that
can work in the sense that he's like oh
wow she's doing okay for herself but he
sees you with another dude that night
that penetrates your my ex run Perelman
right
no you're fu but if you were a [ __ ]
guy like oh wow she's doing things I
don't give a [ __ ] don't do it having a
great time after this says something
right right I'd like him to see that
you're having fun that this didn't have
that impact on you I'd love you to go
out and have a great time tonight and
take some pictures of it not work
pictures of fun take fun pictures and
Roxy if you were saying you're worried
about rocks not being intimate with
people again because Jim was able to do
it with two people and you don't have
that option that's not true because Jim
you've hired them you know they're nots
not true is that true Jim no you know
you didn't pay for their services oh yes
I misunderstood I'm a funny guy look at
me I'm younger than I look at a lot of
people
the irony is lost I know they think
you're actually trying to be cool please
come you on let's do a picture I have to
the show they don't think you're cool
this was great
Jon Taffer you're always amazing you can
watch bar rescue
basically on Paramount TV and you know I
mean you could tell I watch two shows
and I watch two channels okay I watch
Shark Tank because it's on CNBC all the
time and I watch Bar rescue because it's
on Paramount TV all the time the new
episodes are on Sundays but it's on
constantly watch them all you know watch
them always watch them watch inside
information please do I have not said
on the air anyplace else I start my new
show in two weeks what's the new show
I'm doing a new show for Paramount I
can't tell you the name what's it about
coffee but it's a weight radio show it's
all about relationships not businesses
mm-hmm and I'm rescuing relationships
all right and we're shooting it in the
Caribbean and it's it's a very different
departure from Bar rescue I start
shooting it in two weeks that's great
people we didn't even do a pilot we went
right to series and we're gonna figure
it out down here in a couple weeks but
I'm pretty excited about it's just a
second show now let me ask you this is
it a situation maybe where you put
people into situations where there could
be temptation to misbehave no and then
you point out their misbehavior no it's
more about making them behave their
lives not disrupting them oh you I will
I hope you have to do shows called blow
him more